et direction moscou s'est tenu ce matin
une conférence sur les relations entre
la russie et l'union européenne
un événement organisé par le conseil
russe pour les affaires internationales
l'ambassade du portugal et la délégation
de l'ue à moscou
à cette occasion le chef de la
diplomatie russe s'est exprimée compte
rendu de notre correspondante à moscou
vera goffman l'europe ait perdu son
indépendance et le sens de la réalité a
déclaré le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov
en examinant l'état des relations russo
européennes et le ministre a regretté
l'emprise américaine sur le continent
européen
je vous propose d'écouter ce jeu mais
malheureusement je constate que le
parapluie américain a fait que les
européens ont perdu leur indépendance
est tout simplement le sens de la
réalité leur capacité à évaluer d'une
manière adéquate les nouveaux défis qui
se posent ainsi que les meilleurs moyens
d'y répondre
du point de vue de leurs intérêts et des
intérêts fondamentaux communs de
l'europe
pour le ministre aux russes elles le
danger de la situation actuelle et que
son évaluation est éclipsée par des
narrative d'une moscou méchante ce qui
n'a rien à voir avec la politique réelle
de la russie
la situation est d'autant plus grave car
c'est le narratif constitue un fondement
idéologique pour une construction
militaire contre la russie écoutait
l'union européenne a décidé de s'isoler
de la russie en reproduisant en même
temps des déclarations selon lesquelles
ce sont nous qui ne respectons pas lieu
et nous efforçons de diviser l'europe
unie en privilégiant des liens
bilatéraux avec les pays membres de l'ue
eux
je tiens à souligner une fois encore si
n'importe quel pays européen est
intéressé par des contacts avec nous et
bien évidemment nous ne suivrons pas de
tels contacts et j'espère que bruxelles
le comprends parfaitement bien
actuellement des sanctions illégitime
unilatérales imposées selon le principe
d'attribution arbitraire à la discrétion
de l'union européenne se multiplient
contre notre pays
des allégations sans fondement de type
highly la clis ont préféré à un dialogue
basé sur des faits et la présomption
d'innocence a été remplacé par la
présomption de culpabilité tout
simplement par définition afin de sortir
de ce cercle
vaisseau d'aliénation mutuel selon le
ministre russe
il faut s'écouter s'entendre discuter en
se basant sur des faits et prendre
conscience de l'avenir du continent
européen